das Thema über das heute jeder Deutsche
eigentlich spricht bewegt auch mich das
Kanzler Machtwort was mich nämlich
verwundert ist so ein bisschen der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
empfindet jetzt nämlich die von Scholz
getroffene Entscheidung als ein Weg mit
dem ich gut arbeiten und leben kann das
sagt der Habeck auf jeden Fall am
Montagabend in den all die Tagesthemen
das klang auf dem Parteitag der Grünen
am 14 Oktober nur drei Tage vor dem
Kanzler Rums nun ja ein ganz wenig
anders hören wir doch mal rein
wahrscheinlich ist es auch nicht falsch
zu vermuten dass die Botschaft
eigentlich war die doch zurück zu
Atomkraft das ist falsch und das wird
auf keinen Fall mit uns passieren nicht
mit der Bundesregierung nicht mit den
Grünen in der Bundesregierung und nicht
mit Steffi und nicht mit mir
ja das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz
erfahren heute verstehen sie das oder
sind die Grünen eigentlich wenn man es
platt sagt ein wenig verlogen